[Music]
three two one
welcome back to off-the-record where
it's kind of a weird day we're still
going to talk where the [ __ ] we want
because we're here why not why not
might as well and there's only five of
us yeah notice of us there's a song it's
a close look at sorry look at that look
at Beach Boys new lady over there she's
very talkative she's got a lot of
interesting life stories my recognize
Harry from from the wall she moved the
whole like 20 feet so it all seriousness
you can tell we're a little short today
I didn't I actually didn't plan it like
this to have more people there but
unfortunately is there something going
around because a lot of people are sick
like even me I have like stuff I had
stomach issues this morning Nelson had
stomach issues this morning I went
against what the waitress told me to do
you know yeah we went we it's all
because because or not showing up at all
right let's just go get breakfast so we
went to IHOP and then what does this guy
order for breakfast take it yes we'll
give you a second I'll give you say this
like Dora the Explorer all right what
did Nelson get for breakfast it was a
brunch burger a bronzer
[Applause]
oh but then I was like aces have like I
feel like this [ __ ] the meats always
really dry right so I was like hey
waitress lady there's a reason for that
can i order the meat medium rare or does
it have to come well-done and she has
she was like what normally comes all
done no she says usually you have to get
usually you can get it just said you
have to get it well-done
and then she was like but if you want a
medium rare you have to accept full
responsibility what happens yeah that
shoot ribs she whipped out a [ __ ]
waiver and then a will well we can make
it medium split the middle ground
I like the way that she after she took
Brian's order she was getting ready to
walk away but then when you brought up
that going she walked all the way back
to you and walked right in front of you
and she was like are you sure
listen buddy I don't know if you forgot
was like okay you know they rebranded as
I hop burgers have to be decent they
couldn't publish it if it wasn't true
deeper yeah but no but yeah I was like
there has to be a halfway decent I'm
gonna push it at least it has to be at
least medium but it came out and I was
like this is actually kind of medium
rare and I'm kind of scared yeah I did
I'm gonna do it he's a do or [ __ ]
finished it and I say I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna do that as we're
leaving he's like Oh
oh I don't feel so good take some bets
am I gonna throw up in the middle of
this take like your jungle Asian stomach
we'll keep it together at least your
Filipino stomach will hold together yeah
respect for the jungle Asians
progressively more and more pale yeah
more sweaty that's a job agent dream
they'll be like I'm getting more pale
what Richard just pour in sicker
yeah but less other people will be
showing up later in the day but for
right now or like [ __ ] we're gonna roll
it and I'm also kind of grumpy so I want
it to [ __ ] about my grumpy Ryan because
things are going to plan today I had a
dream that I don't know if any of you
guys have dreams about like a prophetic
dream yeah like one of those where you
feel like it's so vivid that it has to
mean something so I was and this is the
second time I've had this dream where I
would get in an elevator and I'm trying
to get back up to my hotel room and then
it you guys been on Tower of Terror
right you know how [ __ ] luck that
[ __ ] launches you like up in the air
and then yeah so it goes like that so
you feel like you're getting squished
down in the elevator and then it gets to
the top and it stopped and you're like
float for a little bit and you get that
like floating feeling in your stomach
and then it dropped me all the way back
down to like the like underground floor
and then it just keeps doing that up and
down up and down with it did you like
feel this insane yeah everything and I
hate that feeling I [ __ ] hate that
feeling you like I like I like the
sensation of going fast I don't like the
sensation of dropping cuz when it drops
I feel like something wrong you know
roller coaster that goes straight yeah
turns or whatever that's fine but like
yeah we did it like not freefall
yeah when it takes me to the top and
then it drops I'm just like god damn it
yeah I think you want to ride on the
back of a motorcycle is that what that
feels like is that one it goes straight
and fast there's no drop is this my
chewing five gun feels yeah but then I
had that dream and I woke up and I was
like huh well it's like one of those
like jolted awake cousins does it go man
I couldn't go back to sleep and then on
top of that everyone's sick and then
it's raining so that was pouring eyes
worried that everyone's gonna get here
safely or not do I was afraid I was
gonna show up like really late like 10
or 11 because I had a migraine earlier
oh oh yeah CNN Julie because I took like
some ID yeah the wonders of pharmacy
drugs drug love drugs and then yeah so
just it just been a morning but I mean
otherwise we just spin it we just
finished like the whole Black Friday
Cyber Monday we can do you guys buy
anything cool things we bought I did so
so for the longest time I wasn't
interested in buying a switch but then
because I see people around me playing
the new Pokemon sword and silver I
bought a silver not even soul silver
just silver with the Hokie all the way
the old the og silver
you still have your Game Boy Color I
still do you still I wish I still had my
hmm yeah but I bought it for sword and
shield which one did you get sword
silver so many okay I know mine last
last Black Friday just in preparation
for a smash oh like three times then
that I've got my smash and I switched so
far just by bringing it to JK party days
does the lunch
I use my switch so little like when you
guys came over you guys were like your
switches completely dead I'm like I
don't even know that could happen you
just left it alone it would I go to
sleep but the battery dies I die yeah
but then we literally brought the PC
from your room to play jack box we
hooked it up
Nelson was drunk as [ __ ] so we all
wanted to go into his but in his living
room this whole party wanted to be like
he was like let's play jack box like
that sounds like fun
and then at first it was like okay let's
get his Xbox working and then it wasn't
turning out he's like boy night life was
no guy no guys you just gotta like you
take take the power kit with long yeah
it has this weird power like problem
where I won't turn on sometimes and I
figured that I figured out that it was
the the power block they and I'll think
if I just shorten the electricity well
yes so the ezel
sitting here like like slowly like
trying to like start a fire doing defeat
we started switching outlets putting
into different outlets around the mouse
house and then eventually were just like
no Nelson it's not gonna work she's
trying on the switch she's like my
switch is dead oh my god Nelson he's
like it wouldn't turn on either when I
plugged it is that to charge and then we
[ __ ] brought your PC all the way to
the living room
and then we finally got it working or
whatever but then we had like rearranged
a bunch of stuff we had to pull the TV
out and you're just really my Steam
account to get it to work yet everybody
at that point was just like I don't want
to play anymore then Nelson was like
yelling doing something I'm doing it all
right yeah literally after everybody
else was over it just did not care
anyway then we try playing it I was like
ma'am too drunk for this game you know
like whiplash on when you come out funny
Cher
and I realized if I'm drunk enough I'm
not coming up with anything that yeah
really simple just like oh yeah pretty
no not even I'm like oh yeah even drunk
every drunk him knows it's not a girl
wasn't a good joke yeah yeah - wit it
was cool too because then I guess like
then the switch that is out now is like
a longer battery life yeah the same
price as when it first yeah I heard
about that
and I got $25 off from Amazon nice all
right not offer back yeah yeah I told
you five dollar gift card right yeah
yeah no to spend right back in I was on
what a deal drug dealers work oh yeah I
assume so okay no no nice sweet I'm
never buying camera gear I was like
traffic or I just trying to convince
myself the entire like Black Friday I
was like I don't need one thing I do
love about Black Friday and hearing
about people's buys it's like on brand
all the time yeah she bought Pokemon
Friday thing I bought camera gear what a
guy
I bought a table saw yeah on branch yeah
yeah look of our bid welder I couldn't
find any good still on brand yeah I
bought 5.1 speakers I was looking at
some I wanted some Costco had 450 bucks
Vizio 5.1 whoo at most one adobe
dtsef7gc
that means you gonna watch the irishman
no spend 3 hours of my life sitting
there watching the Irishman yeah three
hours but if you guys want to have a
movie night Hoffa
once I get Oh I mean Brett meet Brandon
I've already seen it rains like almost
all the way no Freddie yes granny on the
movie if you guys haven't seen the
Irishman yet definitely check it out if
you like Scorsese if you don't like
Scorsese
this is [ __ ] you guys the most movies
ever just imagine Goodfellas but even
all the slow Goodfellas like a really
slow good fellow and entertaining the
entire time I'd say the only thing that
made me sad is that like all these guys
you watch them when they were at their
peak and then now that they're now
they're definitely like now that they're
old and fat yeah I mean yeah honestly
like sorry like kind of like in there
and they just don't have the same kind
of energy that they had when they were
like younger obviously but I mean ice
bucket Al Pacino in this movie as as
Jimmy Hoffa I don't think that's
actually how Jimmy Hoffa sounds but
through the dark like this what is that
it's a it's about a hitman for the for
the Italian mafia now I've said in the
past we need to make a skit where Ryan
plays every character do like eight
different a different impressions I'm
really enjoying doing that the Al Pacino
voice so I kinda want to be Elvis you
explain the summary into Al Pacino voice
oh [ __ ] up my throat No Al Pacino
talking to han Solo
no my my Harrison Ford in fiction I
enjoy most when it's like what Air Force
would they get off my plane I can go
pretty good Mickey Mouse and your goofy
[Laughter]
goofy voice because I enjoy I enjoy the
kids characters like saying really
[ __ ] up things is like it's like what
you say it's just a 10 times funnier
when you say like like cartoon
characters that are not supposed to be
vulgar vulgar voice my friends when was
it is name
you went up to he's like knocking loved
you I think I would have thrown up at
that poopy costume you would just seem
like I just throat or whatever like no I
was not very good
oh yeah yeah Irishman's about a hit man
uh-huh
Italian mob yeah it's a it's a really
interesting story it's definitely very
violent but not in a like I feel like
you're like Goodfellas is way more like
a Tarantino yeah it was never felt like
cartoonish like I feel like some fancy
no violence yeah let's deal with
politics a lot more oh yeah this one has
a lot of I would be interested in like
corruption and you know it's not like I
knew you guys know who Jimmy Hoffa is
yeah he's a union organizer for the UH
for the labor unions back in like the
50s or 60s yeah and then he disappeared
nobody knows what happened oh yeah there
was there was like Mythbusters the way
they didn't episode on like where did
they bury his body yeah because like one
of the rumors is that they killed him
and then the mob killed him and then
they put him in the Yankee Stadium it
was but he's in like the foundation like
the concrete blocks of it they like put
his body in and then they concrete it
over they put other like blocks on
Mythbusters in an episode on
to see if you could do it what was the
result I don't remember why would you
putting a pig in the concrete and seeing
how if it would rot and if you could
smell it through the concrete Oh cuz it
was it the myth that you could smell it
the myth is that that that it would
perfectly seal with it because the idea
was that if his body was rotting someone
would have noticed something you know do
you know I don't think so I don't think
that they smelled it I think that it
like once it harden up and everything
who's an Imagineer
yeah but it was yeah the thing kind of a
gross idea to like get frozen and all
the bodies now you think about it yeah
how many bodies there could be yeah in
the stadium yeah walking at Disneyland
below you dude imagine like those you
know the bricks you see in the front
those donation bricks look those are all
like cremated like isn't there one of
the misses that like Walt Disney's body
is like cryogenically frozen Towers
hedging leaf I believe that though
Futurama is gonna happen bro they're
gonna come back with a head to roll by
little buddy rich ass people would
probably want to do it I feel like it'll
be really funny though because I feel
like a lot of people have this like
idealized version of what they think a
lot of their celebrities and like other
like historical figures are like but if
they come back and meet the person in
person wow you're a dick really really a
lot of my surprise a lot of our founding
fathers I'm sure like sure they had good
ideas but I'm sure they were not perfect
so I'm just imagining like all these
people were like yeah George Washington
was great and then like bring a vacuum
is like yeah oh they're not whoa I kind
of like [ __ ] everyone's view of things
so I think yeah some people just need to
stay dead yeah you guys stay dead well I
wasn't I don't think anyone was arguing
to bring back hit let me some people are
all right yeah dude Majan like if you
could just like go into like a Hitler
like just like I mean meet and greet
with Hitler like a head or whatever just
do a whole my hundred on Hitler yeah
yeah you can get Hitler's a special
bowler flavors Oh bubble flavors boba Oh
Bobo
right now like if you had to choose
between I'm gonna change it okay so over
the break cuz of Thanksgiving right my
brother actually came my brother
actually came back home run and he
rarely comes home for the holidays
because he's usually up in NorCal you
look up an arc and you works I'll tell
ya NorCal yeah so he barely guess I
don't think he has a lot of like time
off so he actually managed to come down
for Thanksgiving and it was really cool
because after dinner my dad was super
adamant about wanting to try the
teachers I saw your store like like I
told him like hey but before you come in
just know that bull bear like part of
their branding is that they duty but
then they also have a hookah lounge at
the same time and then my dad was like
what and then he walked in and they have
like a front right where like it looks
like really clean and my dad was like
there's like no seating in here I'll say
oh no no it's like on side he was like
oh I see and he still sat down and he
looked at the menu and then he saw my
picture and he smiled because like heels
like dad is your teacher exact like I
want to try it and all like yeah I mean
we can go right now and he was like yeah
yeah yeah let's go yeah it was really
cute and then he was like looking at the
two and he was like oh what are they and
I was like well really depends on your
mood because I like them both equally
but just like which one did he end up
liking more um he liked the the apple
fruit ginger tea so it's basically apple
grapefruit honey ginger mint not the
milky one but apparently the milk do you
wanna say like I feel like a lot of
people between the two I do like the
fruity one better but I feel like more
people tend to end up going with like
milk teas and stuff like that no I'm
more of a fruit tea drinker yeah
comment in the section below what's your
what's your favorite between milk cheese
and like normal day after they try her
dream it's one of those let us know
which one's better
yeah it's child would you choose
location that I've barrel adji and it's
only available to the end of this year
we're two locations that biology is
intended need them all there's a bull
bear location and Rowland and I think
there's one in k-town and I think one in
the Westside so we just have to make
sure we go by the end of 2008 does it
cost
I think 650 650 a glass jar with it will
you be there huh will you be there I
know well I do that sometimes you'll
catch me maybe definitely be there yeah
oh yeah basil definitely yeah make sure
I was like I took that picture
yeah just like take a picture next to
her face and then tiger yeah yeah it's
like the same thing just like that like
time out I I made them with my heart and
soul and Ryan was there the whole I was
watching her just like frustrate this
[ __ ] about that you know whenever they
have like those guests make me I'm like
did they really make it oh man a point
that I wanted to curate not only make
some really bad ones first yes like the
one that worked out you're like well
there was a lot of people there that was
taste testing giving their own input and
stuff in the owner of buh-buh-bear but
because the owner of over basically gave
her some like templates or he's like I
think that these fit the flavors that
you're going for you taste them she's
like this is good but let me just change
all this [ __ ] he was like I was like
filming this I was like I mean it's only
it's not like he doesn't own a bunch of
- whatever he was filming every but yeah
it was a she definitely made a lot of
stinkers there it came out to be great
in the end yeah Lana Lana culinary LA
how narrow about four hours it was well
yeah this is a while
the footage you know after a while I
kind of stopped I was like alright she's
been it's gonna be the same footage
julia realizes the cameras still been
rolling ever there was like almost 50
gigs of footage that I edited that
wasn't even 4k or anything it was like
just almost a full card full of just I
want this what more do I think the
funnier footage is definitely looking at
the owner of overbear tell me yeah and
watching him just like look watch as you
go through all of his ingredients just
like they got like a bag of apples for
her to use he would panic every single
time I would eat like a slice of apple
or something and he'd be like stop
eating on the job it's that sad tale
like I'm making my treats like it's not
sanitary
okay no you guys gonna get a recording
all of it too so he's just like the
trouble though yeah I think I think so
yeah the the damn product was was pretty
cool yeah you could you could see the
video of me making my tea drink on my
channel levels who edited a video I did
it yeah she did yeah and then Ryan
helped me film it and then he was also
my taste tester but yeah that was a very
whole die so that's all the banne I was
there later - oh yeah you were yeah have
you ever thought about rebranding your
blue apples name no really no it's so
classic hey yeah I know I am stealing
the domain and copyright right now as we
speak
no it's just that I feel like what
nowadays people are using their actual
names I'm like yeah please man like Vic
stick true to who you are man I want to
stay with X blue levels to the day I
[ __ ] die other people full name is
y'all right so I'm gonna say X blue
apples honest F Jules
yeah and my net elastic like it it's so
like my space reminiscent of the time
when you were like I'm gonna throw X's
ever because edges are cool it looks
cool look at how cool look strip Ram
this won't be inconvenient to tell
anybody in the future at all you know I
tried to make it Instagram account with
just blue apples and then that was
already taken so like I guess I'll do
the extra Asian thing I had an X in
front of it and it just stayed yeah oh
my gosh Maya my aim like SN was the most
embarrassing it was a cuz I thought
dragons were the [ __ ] right so it was X
dragon and co like in company X but the
problem the problem came because there
was an X at the end and it said call X
so became X dragon [ __ ] people know me
for a long time now I should who I am
they shouldn't be definitely you deserve
that you deserve every bit of that
Instagram handle back to that yeah I can
cause this dragon Hawk do dragons have
talks though apparently I'm sure that
they do that's kind of scary